we're going through the review period
we're very lucky that we have the best
negotiator at the table in the president
it'll be a couple months before tariffs
on either side would go into effect and
be implemented and we're hopeful that
China will do the right thing
look China created this problem not
president Trump White House most woman
Sarah Huckabee Sanders today describing
the state of trade relations between the
US and China time to bring in our panel
Steve Hayes of the Weekly Standard Molly
Hemingway from the Federalist in Charles
Lane of The Washington Post so Steve
China I think it's fair to say struck
back harder today than most people
expected announcing tariffs on 50
billion dollars of US exports including
soybeans which is really key a big
market in China for the US soybeans and
also aircraft but no dates were set and
the Trump administration says it's not
setting a date it's going to go through
a process that goes into mid or late May
so are we in a trade war with China or
not we're often close if we're not there
already look the the big question is
whether this is bluster from the Trump
administration and then a strong
pushback I certainly a stronger push
back than many in the Trump
administration had anticipated you had
Peter Navarro saying that he didn't
expect that others would retaliate
anyway because they would recognize that
we were just trying to balance what the
Trump administration sees as a trade
imbalance and lo and behold we're seeing
pretty serious retaliation I think the
Chinese were smart and strategic about
how they retaliate it's very clear that
they picked industries and products that
are helpful the economy's in red states
where Donald Trump did well or states
that Donald Trump won in those are
obviously going to be potentially
politically painful for the president if
in fact this goes through I would say as
somebody who believes in free trade I
was encouraged today by some of the
rhetoric coming from the White House we
are a long way from the president's
declaration just four weeks ago that
trade wars are good and easy to win
we're now hearing people like Larry
Kudlow and others saying look trade wars
aren't good the president's a free
trader we want to trade freely we just
don't want to be screwed in the process
Somali are we in a trade war or not
I think the situation is that for the
last several decades the United States
and other global entities have tried to
treat China like one of the big boys in
the hopes that they would rise to the
occasion that as they had a greater
participation in the global economy they
wouldn't be doing all of their human
rights abuses they wouldn't continue
their unfair trade practices they're
dumping their intellectual property
theft and what's happened is they
haven't I mean they've really benefited
from being allowed to be part of that
global economy but they haven't changed
these practices there's worse as ever
they support North Korea they have they
have gained quite a bit and we haven't
gotten much in return so I think what
people are trying to do is push back
against some of this and people who do
oppose tariffs and tariffs are attacks
on the people they do have economic
costs they also achieve some pressure
against other countries so people who
don't think that we should use tariffs
to fight just this massive intellectual
property theft that comes from China
should probably come up with some other
good ways to deal with this problem you
know it is interesting Chuck because the
the the futures and the Dow Jones were
down 500 points and in fact the market
dropped 500 points today it ended up up
230 points so that's what a 730 point
swing clearly the market was persuaded
by the end of the day that we're not
headed for a trade war at least not
immediately and that there's a
possibility that this bluster and and
talk about tariffs may end up in a deal
if so I think the market is right there
is a possibility but we don't know and
it's going to take probably a few months
to come to rest on this I have been
reporting on this for the post over the
last week or so I've been reporting on
trade for a long time and what struck me
about my conversation this week with
people who are free traders and who
support the WTO is how many of them even
many Democrats will privately say the
president is dealing with a real problem
here with respect to China that China
has been stealing American intellectual
property China bars US investors from
operating in China unless they agree to
turn over their technology and even many
of these free traders are saying you
know if it takes tariffs to get their
attention and bring them to the table
for that the question of course is once
there at the table who has more leverage
who's going to be better able to get to
a deal and ultimately what the
president's endgame is what his real
objective is and on that one I think
there's still a little bit of
uncertainty then there is the southern
border and here was the Secretary of
Homeland Security Nielsen at the White
House today the president has directed
that the Department of Defense and the
Department of Homeland Security work
together with our governor's to deploy
the National Guard to our southwest
border to assist the Border Patrol the
president will be signing a proclamation
to that effect today Molly there was
some suggestion and in John Roberts
reporting that the president's real goal
here yes he's going to send the the
National Guard and yes he wants to help
protect the border but the real point
here is to try to put more pressure on
Congress to finances wal every president
since Reagan has sent troops to the
border so it's not totally new that this
president would do that we don't have
specifics on exactly what he's thinking
that way this is a very politically
sensitive issue and you and he keeps on
trying to draw them throughout the
contrast between Republican approaches
and Democratic approaches and Democrats
in particular feel that this is a good
issue for them to have more lacks
enforcement at the border to allow more
people to enter the country illegally
follow up with amnesty programs without
ever actually fixing the border it was a
huge issue that he succeeded that that
went well for him during the campaign to
highlight that border enforcement is
lacs and that we don't have a really
sensible immigration policy so the more
he can highlight this the better for him
I want to get and we have about a minute
left in this segment Steve - one more
thing and that is the news today that
special counsel robert muller apparently
told the president's lawyers that he is
not the target of a criminal
investigation but he is the subject of a
criminal investigation as part of an
effort to get him to sit down to testify
and that the focus seems to be much more
on the issue of obstruction of justice
than collusion with the Russians what do
you make of all that well it's a good
news for the president with an asterisk
I mean it's good news for the president
now as we speak now of course as others
with far more expertise in this to
matter than
and I have have pointed out that can
change at any given moment I think
there's no reason to believe that it
will change we've likely would have
heard about the significant evidence of
the kind of collusion that people were
talking about a year ago or when Robert
Maude was appointed if it if Robert
Mahler had it I say all of that and then
caution yet again there's a lot we don't
know at this point and then of course
there's also the question of how the
president would perform and what he
would say your thoughts about what this
development which was in your paper well
the president said it again today I want
to talk to him I want to talk to him and
he's been said that a number of times
and his lawyers are waving him off
because they fully understand the real
hazard here is the potential perjury
trap that he would he would blunder into
saying something false and get in
trouble for that